hello everybody and welcome back to the
fan scription podcast I'm Walter bond
easyacc with Rob yes Rob walkers here
with me to discuss his ghostbusters to
revamp our title for the episode just
what if Ghostbusters 2 was better
because we couldn't think of anything
else ideal I think I could think it was
like what if it didn't have a baby
I know when I was like that trivializes
it could you redo everything so I was
like we gotta just say it was better so
yeah you have a lot of thoughts on this
this basically started back when you
guys are doing the Stata critic review
of it right yeah this was like I guess
the original fan scription cuz when we
did that whole little bit in the middle
of the nostalgia critic review where
it's just like yeah start the movie off
like this and the number of people are
like you guys should just like talk
about that like how to fix movies and
stuff like that and then you had your
idea for like what ifs with like rocky
and stuff so it kind of just like
collided yeah yeah I pitched a show like
this a long time ago like a year ago and
then like you guys did the Ghostbusters
one and that's kind of one be like oh we
have the same idea let's just do the
show
caption was born baby yeah half from
this at least so I did want to ask cuz a
lot of people were asking the comments
this is a rare thing because we're
recording this after the video has
already been out for a while oh I don't
seem to really like it and are into it
so I think a lot of that is because it
was I'm the Nostalgia Critic episode and
I think a lot of people want to know you
know you co-wrote that episode with Doug
right yeah so what what did you keep and
what did you expand on from that into
this I mean with the brain the thing we
kept was cuz that was like the one big
thing I noticed and what bothered me
about Ghostbusters 2 when we were
watching it again is I was telling Doug
I'm like what kid wants to see this the
Ghostbusters are washed up and not
busting goes it takes them like 40
minutes before they get to any ghost
busting in the courtroom scene I'm like
if they wanted them to be like kind of
washed up and that was the idea it was
like the shoes just gone through really
quickly I'm like start off with the
court scene and then do this and I was
like feeding Doug these lines and he was
like typing him down and then Doug did
it is like only Duncan do he's like
there
like so it is made me realize like yeah
we just fast forwarded through all of
this stuff sure that was taking forever
so that was exactly the same when I
started like I'm going through like a
house right now and doing all sorts of
stuff so I broke this over like two
nights super tired just
stream-of-consciousness style which is
probably why it was so long but that was
just the same I'm like okay what did
Doug say in the review and I just in the
expansion of the ideas yeah UK he was
helping me out particularly with like
the second half because I had like the
first half kind of in mind so I went
over the Doug's place and we were
brainstorming ideas he he and I he
literally came up with the same idea
about Peck talking to his dead father
but I was talking to Doug about it I was
like yeah so I have this scene where
we're Peck man like pecks like no you
you should believe these gentlemen and
it's like why it's like well I was
talking to my mother and my brother and
Doug says and my mother's been dead for
14 years I'm like you freaking read my
mind man he was helping me like with the
statue stuff I love that man could you
send this to me and you were like I
really rushed this is it's not my best
work cuz I was like this is freaking
awesome be talking about I wrote this
like with one eye like half open like I
was half asleep yeah I wrote this right
after see to me too so we weren't out
from that I mean I was just worried
because I'm like I don't know I don't
have a lot of time to finish this here
you go what came together really really
well and then I was I was suggesting
what I want to do more often on the show
which is bring in the other people from
channel awesome to voice different
characters and stuff I thought that
flowed really well I thought that was
cool because I had just read all the
parts myself and I'm like I don't sound
like a woman you boys Princess Leia
pretty well that's totally true just
saying if you need a replacement for
Carrie Fisher don't go with me ya know
uh so he helped me a lot like kind of
putting that last third into some
semblance of order yeah
our only big we had two big
disagreements
one was he wanted Dana become a
Ghostbuster I did not her Sigourney
Weaver like in interviews pretty much
said that she thought she was like the
straight woman in a Marx Brothers story
which is also what William Atherton kind
of said he thought he was the straight
man in a Marx Brothers store and they
both went with that metaphor I mean
that's what he that's what Mary
over-the-top like watching I haven't
seen the movies yet he's completely hard
right is that that battle smart that
shit-eating grammar house like like what
is the magic before he liked those nuts
that's his claim anyway so I agree with
her assessment like what makes her fun
in that movie in both movies really even
though I don't like the sequel as much
is that yeah she is just playing it
pretty straight unless she turns into a
dog in which case she goes over the top
but the idea for being a Ghostbuster it
she doesn't fit with that crowd I mean
we're essentially talking about four
bros and it's not the issue to me isn't
that that she's female cuz I think going
which means a way better idea it's that
she's not you know she's more
sophisticated she works in an orchestra
she's not like a working stiff she's not
really very sardonic she doesn't have
that much of a sense of humor in the
movies like she's very straight like you
go with Janine though she is a working
stiff she knows what's like to work with
these guys she doesn't she takes a lot
of crap and also doesn't want to take a
lot of crap like she's like the perfect
fit like she can be funny right in their
sort of dynamic so I told Doug I'm like
he was really big on that so that was
the one thing where I kind of put my
foot down and that's my show this is my
episode where this is my episode you can
do you goddamn Mary Poppins episode and
do whatever you want you can make Dana
Barrett a Ghostbuster in fact
penguins I don't care all right looking
forward to that fan scription video but
uh no while we're on the subject of of
jeanine really quick you know like I did
notice you know I didn't rewash the
episode the movies until I heard your vo
and stuff so like I was like was Jeannie
really that much different in a second
and like she's like a wacky kinda like I
don't know the hair and I don't care
that's like one of my biggest gripes
about Ghostbusters is I cannot stand
what they did to Janine she just like
she would say she was such a cool
character like in the first one in G but
she was a little more normal
like she were monotone yeah she was she
was a nerd like what they did what
bothers me is like cuz they they wanted
to hook her up with Lewis and I'm like
I'm indifferent to that I'm like I
didn't need that but if they're like
well we don't want to hook her up with
Egon for some reason they wanted to do
it loose so all I can figure is that
they thought like well Janine's way to
like her and Lewis and so what they did
is they dork her up to basically match
with Lewis and I'm like doctor up yeah
she like there's a difference if there's
like a nerd like which is somebody's
like she's in the book she's like these
things like Harold Ramis to me is a nerd
and then there's Lois who is like just
this nerd he's a dork that's what I'm
saying like even more than that yeah
he's like a doofus basically and so like
they're like well we gotta like dork her
up so that this and I'm like why
couldn't you do it like is this so
unbelievable that like a normal woman
wouldn't somehow be attracted to Lewis
as a character I don't know but I'm like
they like took Janine's character and
completely made it this weird goofy like
a bit oh god those scenes where she's
all like I think motherhood is a very
sexy fingers is like these weird
conversation like what is going on he's
sexually charged seems like she's like
playing with the ball between her legs I
know that was weird
zips up she zips up his the jump is
Ghostbuster JumpShip she's got like her
yeah that was another one where I'm just
like why did they make Lois a
Ghostbuster why not G because okay
wasn't Rick
this after honey i shrunk the kids i
think it was this is 89 i think they're
concurrent okay because let us safely
actually the kids is either 89 or 90
okay well I'm not sure that because like
Rick Moranis got like billing over like
a lot of people in this movie know a lot
more than that i have i maybe he got
super popular like i it might have been
right after i you know some I'm sure
will tell us in the comments but I mean
it could have been yeah like really dude
like that's a Bobby's we they made him a
Ghostbuster and he shows up and he's not
even responsible for breaking down the
museum barrier like it's just a
coincidence and I'm just it felt you
know it is it's and this is my problem
with the movie all together it's like it
was for kids the kids like he does this
thing and you get a laugh and I'm just
like I guess but then by the end I mean
the Viggo turn around was not a kids
thing I don't think no well I mean
that's still Ghostbusters yeah but like
when you look at the first film versus
the second like there was one major
event that happened between those two
movies and that was the Real
Ghostbusters right I'm out if you want
to talk about sex I have no frame of
reference on that because I didn't grew
up watching that show or anything is so
basically I never got to see
ghostbusters on the big screen
I saw the cartoon in the movie pretty
much at about the same time so I enjoy I
enjoyed the movie a lot
it was way darker I always had the
feeling that I was watching something I
wasn't supposed to
while watching it which is always a
great feeling as a kid like being
naughty like mom wouldn't want to be
watching this like like a Ghostbuster if
my dad was just like oh you're like that
cartoon huh you should watch this and
then then I guess a kid I'm just like
wow like his terror dogs running around
and so um now the cartoon was very good
it was a kid's cartoon and that's fine
but the fact that it got latched onto by
kids cuz it was initially released it
was a huge hit and they Harold Ramis
like and reitman they called it a
t-shirt movie where basically you would
have all these quotes that would show up
on t-shirts from the film so that's
definitely true when the cartoon came
out though
that's when it became this giant
merchandising you know all the toys Doug
and I had all of these toys like the
ecto-1 and then they were watching the
cartoon like crazy that's when it ceased
to be this kind of movie that like yeah
kids like this well ghostbusters
everybody was into ghostbusters - oh
this is a kid's thing right okay and
when you watch Ghostbusters - you can
totally tell that now they're making a
movie for kids it's the first one was
not right it seems like they're very
self-aware of that though because they
had that scene at the beginning we're at
the kid's birthday party and stuff it's
like they're pandering the kids playing
the Ghostbusters which made no sense
because in 1989 like I can remember I
was like 10 years old and I remember
Doug and I we stayed we talked about
this in a review just staring at the
screen going what a bunch of ungrateful
little brats I would kill them because
Buster's fever in 1989 sure sure and it
made no sense as a child watching that
my jaw drop like what kill like man
well did Jim I was talking to Jim Gary's
about this he's like yeah that's why I
didn't get it's like 1989 I remember
well he-man was kind of getting on the
ice wasn't he man know when I was a kid
growing up watching ghostbusters - this
is like early 90s I guess 93 94
something like that I was just like
he-man like I know what he is my problem
you have when a bunch of adults try to
write for kids because I'm just like
this is I can't write Harold Ramis like
trying to remember what their kids I'm
just throwing it in it also doesn't even
make much sense because later it's very
obvious that they're popular with kids
because remember when they're going in
to see the mayor and like all kind of
get an autograph for my little brother
or something like oh yeah so why are
they like dude why don't they do that
scene why weren't they really popular
with the kids and they come out there
they could still be exhaust the whole
stoop the whole first part of that movie
makes no sense right
and it yeah like I did want to bring up
if you have no more thoughts on that
okay so Winston's character Ernie Ernie
Hudson mm-hmm why is he treated like
such trash and he's - movie
I don't okay like oh the first the first
film gets a bit of a pass
I kind of there's two yeah it was very
difficult for me to find single shots of
him in this like you know when when we
would cut to him when we had Malcolm
voice in there in this episode it was
very difficult to find shot just single
shots of him and there's it's it's
comedic hot the blocking in this movie
and in the first one too well they had
these big hero shots with her pushing in
on the dolly and Winston's like hiding
behind like Bill Murray or something and
the other three are like front and
center but what the Freak are they doing
that for in the first movie he was
initially he Eddie Murphy was I know I
know that it was dry so but what I found
out is it wasn't his last minute what
happened was they were realizing that
the way that the script was running they
didn't have certain of the main three
having enough line so they at some point
pulled some of Winston's lines away and
then eventually Winston was like well
he's gonna be the everyman in this movie
we're gonna give him basically it's
gonna be he's gonna get yours in right
yeah and in so in the first movie once
he shows up he's there it's just that he
doesn't show up until like the middle of
the movie yeah if that I think it's even
more like the last third I give it a
pass there because like they still
didn't know what they were don't like ya
know when you have one under tuned in
and you have the cartoon come out and
he's a big he's a big part in the
cartoon when you have like now this is
firmly established and it's like now we
get to do a sequel I for the life of me
don't get why they just did it all over
again where it's just like no he's not
he wasn't there like when they went down
into the Van Horne station so he shows
up for one line at the courtroom scene
right yeah he's like well good luck guys
he says that when their bus ooh he's not
he's not helping at the end where do you
go again and like it kills me cuz I love
Ernie Hudson he's like any movie he's in
he's like a good luck charm he's like
Tim crazy grin the crow oh yeah man any
like alpha Congo I freakin love him with
a little evolution
Congo actually was a twofer confident
even hurry and Ernie Hudson this makes
any even if the movie sucks he just
makes it better
yeah I like Christopher Walken or any of
these character actor so I don't I don't
know why but it pissed me off so I'm
like alright well I'll give Winston
something to do in this no
that was a really good thing about this
episode that I really like is you gave
him like that literal fear that you talk
about like everyone else is kind of
doing more existential cut yeah and his
was like because he fell into like the
right you're going we're going into this
slime and then going directly into the
ghost dimension stuff which is something
for it cuz like a lot of the themes were
more adult like Peter having to accept
responsibility and of being pregnant
like Winston's is more something I think
kids can latch I'm sure absolutely
kid doesn't care about responsibility
but right facing monsters that someone
yes they can get on board with it when
he's in the movie he's great I'm talking
about the second one but yeah it's just
he's ha mikhyl like he's going to my
favorite lines which is you know you're
not sleeping with it are you right it's
like oh you don't and then he says it's
quite whoa that was a good scene too but
some saying like when the four of them
together the chemistry works of what was
the motivation on keeping him out of so
many scenes I don't understand I don't I
don't know maybe it's like I don't got
enough time to do their stuff we're
gonna have to cover these lines I don't
know I don't know the reason from a
script perspective it could be the fact
that those three had worked together on
SNL and sctv before so maybe they had a
decent camaraderie I have no idea what
all four of them were together that's
what I'm saying like I agree which three
is great between all of them I couldn't
I couldn't tell you like I've seen no
it's one of the few things like I looked
um Doug actually brought bought me a
Ghostbusters movie book this past
Christmas I actually looked at an after
I wrote pants and was surprised to see
that there were a couple things in it
that I'm just like oh they had the same
idea like the museum comes to life and
apparently there was storyboards for
this I'm like oh it's awesome see it was
a decent idea they just didn't do it
like I saw a lot of comments about that
like you know it's saying that this the
stuff that you're describing honey came
out in yeah either like book form or
they were in comic books or they are in
of like the 2009 video game a lot of
people said they have similarities to so
if you ever play that game really even
never played the whole game but
everybody I've I've seen chunks of it
okay everybody that I've ever talked to
is own the game and played it says it's
the Real Ghostbusters 3 like this name
which is Lisa and I'm like maybe the
cartoon and video games are where this
sure franchise belongs so in that book
though like there were interviews about
like Ernie Hudson's it's like yeah and
the first movie I felt like I was a
little left out because like there was
so much stuff going on and said things
change I can't find anything that
anybody says about what happened in the
sequel it wasn't in that book so I have
no idea why he was cast aside but it
drove me nuts cuz I'm Ernie Hudson so I
know and the Winston character is great
to like I mean like he should have been
the voice of the audience and stuff and
asking questions and yeah we learn about
things that's a perfect role for him and
we would have connected it to him the
most he could have been doing the action
stuff because of all the other three
ghostbusters are like a little bit older
I think and they're just like not in
good shape
better shape and also their how do I put
it there a little more in the know
because they're the techs I know I get
so yeah it's a great way is a great way
well Peters a smart ass yeah it's a
great way to give like so he's the
outsider looking in right I think it's
an interesting role to play and they
what they didn't they just made him the
outsider he doesn't get to look I don't
know yeah very frustrating that was one
of the main things that I was just you
know be watching them that I noticed
right away and was just kind of upset
about like because like you said Ernie
Hudson's great scene more than would
have been awesome
is he gonna pop up you know let's talk
about I do you anything else you want to
mention about your rewrite that you were
clamoring to talk about before we go
into some other things okay let's talk
about the other movies in the franchise
don't kill us everybody but this movie
which came out in 2016 it's been a few
years now I only saw it once in the
theaters I didn't like it but I didn't
hate it
what were your thoughts on ghostbusters
answer the call or Ghostbusters 2016
because they're like three different
titles for this movie that are out in
the round so we have to forgive
no I Kate McKinnon was great all
honestly it I have seen so many films
that are way worse and I'm sure I have
seen so many films that are way better
than and I'm feeling it
it was so middle of the
odhh that it wasn't worth arguing over
mm-hmm like which is more which other
when i tire in them right yeah well
which is what I thought was gonna happen
I'm like watch it's gonna be like and
when we saw the same thing happen
recently with Captain Marvel or it's
like everybody just big stake a claim on
something because some of the lay and
then when it's all said and done I say a
rumor it's like this wasn't even worth
it but this is just blah and it's the
same thing with this I did I liked three
out of the four of them Kristen Wiig can
be seen on SNL she can be hilarious yeah
whatever reason in this one straight why
I don't know cuz venkman's not a
straight man that's Winston's the
straight man right so if they wanted to
do that like if honestly if I were
making this film I would recast it
whereas Leslie Jones maybe would be like
Ray has all the passion the nard I would
make Kristen week then the Winston who's
brought in later I would keep McKenna as
basically Egon she's I think she's the
best part of the movie for sure she had
like the best jokes a lot of some didn't
land those improv moments but a lot of
them they took they took something I
love about so what I love about
ghostbusters the originals that they're
all not great people
thank Minh the worst hands yes I always
lose when people get this hero worship
but I was like you missed the point he's
a con artist heroic Eric Winston is the
most heroic character there's something
that like Ray has a lot of heart but
he's so loopy but even so kind of like
well he's like each one of us is working
I'm licensed nuclear particle
accelerator on his back right way myself
so he got kind of and he's also mad
scientist yes right what I love and goes
there's that one scene goes was like
let's see what Han we take away the
puppy this guy is actually pretty messed
up he just hides it better and I like
that McKenna like they leaned into that
yeah this is like she's kind of a mad
scientist I the main like it was just
Kristen Wiig was the one where I'm like
she had no personality no character I
know she's funny I've seen her be funny
so it's I'm not saying well she
turned in the bad performance I think
she was asked to well yeah but she had
to kind of be that straight character
and you know in this I mean like the you
needed one of those and everyone else is
so goofy I mean like I hated hate hated
the secretary there's like it was like
some I don't know what the attempted
commentary was Chris ever do you hate
Thor I did oh that was Chris Hemsworth
wasn't it yes it was as I said I've only
seen him once he it was so is one of the
more enjoyable parts than me because no
no no Janine was a real human being
though I agree I agree and this party I
guess it's part of the problem with the
whole movie all together is that it's
skewed away from real human beings or at
least bizarre human beings just
straight-up cartoon characters and like
I remember Doug and I were watching it
and all of his scenes were just kept
looking at each other like what yeah
when I remember the the line and memory
guys focused on this when we were all
talking about it was like when he heard
something really loud I was like oh
that's really loud I was like rubbing
his eyes or something and he has like no
lenses in his glasses yeah so he's like
so I understanding he's like a little
too stupid I get that but I mean like
most of the laughs in this movie came
from either him or cam mackinnon for me
but then by the end for me it was all
games against stuff ya know she's great
that's Leslie Jones kind of funny - I
loved it I liked it I liked Russell
Jones and Melissa McCarthy like I just
yeah the movie my problem I could I
could care less that they're all female
that has nothing to do with it never did
those are you can they have the wingnuts
argue that one I don't care like it the
whole movie could have been all-female
without a single guy in it it's like it
but what sinks or swims and is on the
execution and that's where it blew it
for me right I just I didn't get what
really they were going for the ghosts
the ghosts were hard to me yeah they
were like balloons
I lost it it like the weird Cuban Pete
section from the mask when they do like
a dance like there's like one sex really
and I'm like didn't I see this in the
mask it's just and that's the thing when
I look at it though I'm just like at the
same time I'm like this is the this is
the final like this is the end game now
know everything ghostbusters to start
it's like well we gotta make our family
friend oh we got to do this what can't
be should be scary the knife
it's and I'm just like this was the
result and it's like it's not this isn't
what killed the franchise that started
back in 1989 in some ways the franchise
as we knew it which was ghostbusters 84
that died the second the cartoon came
out right I think you focused on towards
the end of the video I know that you
think that maybe yeah like Real
Ghostbusters kind of killed by making it
a children's property that it kind of
killed yeah and I'm not saying the Real
Ghostbusters is bad it was amazing I
like you really so nostalgic but it yeah
when people talk about like all the
franchise's ruined I'm like the
franchise never had anywhere to go the
second kids latched on to it it was game
over
did you ever watch extreme Ghostbusters
no a lot of people were asking about
that I like saw an episode or two and
was completely dismiss when did I smile
that was like late 90s maybe was it I'm
trying to think when I saw I want to say
it was like I was flipping through
channels and say I feel like I was
either in high school or early college
okay I mean I don't remember it at all I
didn't watch it was it like look like
the yeah from what I remember there was
like I only literally like two episodes
sure it was kind of like in one ear out
there I remember there was Egon I
remember there was like a Venkman
wannabe type he looked like some teen
but he had like he was supposed to be
the Venkman okay I want to say the guy
who was supposed to be maybe Ray was in
a wheelchair and though it was I'm just
gonna hit that Captain Planet like five
guys let's get every single diverse
token character we can and assemble them
into one group and I always say like why
don't you focus on one person like or
one if you want to do that instead of
trying to cram them all into like I cuz
I have no problem with diversity but it
it starts to get a little like okay like
we're just shoving everything we can in
and I'm like well let's see what happens
if the Captain Planet movie that's
coming up I'm sure that'll be stalling
the critic review or something
when that comes out but we probably got
a great cafe plan a movie though with
the Don Cheadle skit that done I know
they're all trees but now I extreme
ghosts is that it's called extreme
Ghostbusters pretty extreme that's
that's what good it was the ultimate cry
for help when you when you put extreme
in your title that is the ultimate
surrender like we give up here's three
we're pandering to uniting these kids
here you go it's got extreme in the
title I mean that that would have been
my like generational thing but I just
never watched it so I mean leave some
comments I guess about what he thought
of extreme Ghostbusters I mean maybe I'm
not given it a fair shake because I
didn't but you know at that point I've
been too old I go I revisit Real
Ghostbusters in like it cuz reminds me
of being a kid but I'm like if Real
Ghostbusters came on right now I'm like
into this like it's hard to separate you
know yeah I mean look at things that you
watch as a kid objectively is very
difficult to do and and like judge the
quality of those things we can't end
this discussion without talking about
the new Ghostbusters movie that's coming
out so alright let me just tell you a
little bit of my experience with this so
I saw that trailer and I was like they
got a trailer already and like the the
video that I watched on YouTube said
Bill Murray movie you know like where it
names like the stars of it I was like oh
they got everyone but alright so this is
like the original Donner's Superman
trailer here's a bunch of names so like
they did that it just showed ecto-1
in like where no it wasn't it's like a
barn or something I think during like a
storm or whatever and just announced
that the movies come out in summer 2020
and jason reitman is gonna be directing
the movie so you know passing down from
ivan reitman to jason reitman that's a
big deal everybody made that a big deal
but and i think everybody expected it
okay this is ghostbusters 3 this is
gonna be the sink-or-swim we're gonna
see what happens like the old men
Ghostbusters they're gonna be all in it
and we're gonna see what happens but
then later I find out that's not what's
happening and a lot of people think
that's still happening but it's not
apparently this is like a goosebumps
style stranger things kind of thing and
even got the kid if in wolf art is in
this
yeah that's about kids in a neighborhood
like finding the Ghostbusters gear or
something but it's in the ghostbusters
like original movie universe so that
makes it okay I guess they could have
easily said this was in the same
universe they could have I mean like if
they just had a we can't do this have
little kids little kids and it's gonna
be much better because that's you know
that's the thing now now we've just
we've just gone full force and well
we'll just cast kids in it I don't know
what kid now knows that much about the
Ghostbusters you know what I mean I mean
like there's been the movie or the
movies they obviously came out and like
the series like all those shows are long
over the movie came out into early the
videogame came out 10 years ago like no
one's playing that game anymore this is
like growing up now this is a problem
which is Ghostbusters was an adult movie
that kids had inadvertently latched on
to and became a huge sensation and it
got picked up by kids was then turned
into a mostly kids property and
Ghostbusters 2 then all those kids grew
up then Ghostbusters 3 comes out
Ghostbusters reboot comes out and
everybody freaks out just like you I
could see the kids forgetting that they
safe through Ghostbuster students kids
and didn't really have a problem and now
like what is the next generation the
next generation the only thing they've
seen now if they didn't get the video
game is this that and I mean I know I
will say this like and I won't take it
away from her I know plenty of parents
are just like my kids like it and I'm
like that's fine sure I'm my problem is
I'm a grown-ass adult in like at this
point I'm just done with the kids kind
of ghost bus and like I'm just like at
this point I'm like just stop just knock
it off no this has always been my point
which is like I don't I don't care
that's all women I don't care like you
could have all of the original casting
you could literally raise Harold Ramis
from the dead and have him in this movie
and like I would still be like it no
yeah it's it was like a one-shot deal
right but it's tough for that like you
said with all I'm merchandising and
everything and people love these movies
so much well that's what that's why I
think they're doing this the wrong way I
think it either belongs in games or an
animated series or series will be cool
if you wanted to do a stranger thing
series like a 13 episode like I could
have mostly but yeah but the idea of
doing this in a movie where it has to
appeal to everybody like it's just not
you're not gonna get anything but a
bland product yeah I mean we'll see what
happens I mean James being at home I
hope I'm wrong and I like Jason right
with it's right that's obscene like he
said the only reason he had this because
he had an interesting take on the story
so it's like I mean if this is the only
reason he really believes in it it's not
like a cash grab for him this is
obviously like a passion thing for him
so it's like I hope like I hope so and I
hope I'm wrong I I'll gladly admit if I
am wrong and be like cuz I was wrong
about Aleta I thought that was gonna
suck and that movie was amazing so I I
hope I'm wrong I just you know I get
worried when I hear things like it's for
the fans and I'm like who the hell are
the fans at this point nobody even knows
what it's like it's like saying it's for
Star Wars fans what is a Star Wars fan
right now that could be a lot of
different everything yeah everything is
so divided and I'm just like it that's
am like a meaningless statement like
just and the sky is blue cool what does
that mean yeah I also feel like
Ghostbusters you know like we're talking
about how like kids a lot of kids
wouldn't connect to it now except for
this movie but I don't know if it's is
it really it is like an everlasting
property I mean it's a great movie like
the first one the second one I still
like growing up and I still enjoy like
pre watching it now I didn't see any
more there's I'm not saying that's a
thing it's a guilty pleasure for me
there are tons of scenes yeah I love the
ocean Vigo in particular like they need
their own sitcom
I can watch those two all day absolutely
but is go
Buster's like on the same level of like
a back to the future I don't think it's
obviously not on the same level as a
Star Wars we're like it's this
multi-generational thing I don't think
it is I think it's like your generation
kind of my generation are big
Ghostbusters fans and like the people
who come after that aren't as as
indoctrinated as like Back to the Future
fans or Star Wars fans I don't know you
know I don't think it's the franchise is
that like ghostbusters I will say I'm
like back to the future Ghostbusters is
like Star Wars and that it was ruined by
itself over time with sequels and you
know what this the state of Star Wars
now I'm not going to sit here and judge
me like cuz like I see a thousand these
YouTube videos every day oh my god so
dramatic and now everyone's like I like
how it's been flopped because it used to
be the prequels that ruining star know
it's like the prequels oh god yeah
that's the sequels of ruining stone but
certainly the prequels I I don't care
who you are like they so many people
like yeah that ruins Star Wars like
there's been countless and Ghostbusters
I've been sued so many comments yeah so
many requests for us to do fan scripture
on the secret on the prequels like there
are so many videos oh thank you I would
have to rewrite the line outside
I know so like go watch from the other
mid belated media like it would be like
the only thing I would keep is Darth
Maul versus obi-wan remembers about the
first movie like that and that is great
like I said I still love the last
otherwise it's a total net Terra but
loans would be a total even what the
Jedi battle at the end of that that's
like the worst but yeah so back to the
future though that's come out still
probably swimmingly because it never got
rekt right by any of the option
mechanism and Bob Gale are like or have
a stranglehold on the rights to that
movie and they will not let anybody
remake that good for that while they're
alive though but the minute they die
they're going to make a remake of that
movie or a reboot or ever want to call
it the second I'm sure you die it's over
so all we need to do is keep them alive
keep them ever
we're gonna hijack them into the matrix
yes I'm gonna keep them on life support
the entire time they're never gonna die
but you had to answer your question I
think I don't know maybe people in the
comments could tell us if they're like
way younger than us I'm like Oh
Ghostbusters is still big I don't know I
never hear anyone every band young in
high school or younger talk about
Ghostbusters that's just been my you
know I don't know many teenagers so I
can't comment I will say back to the
future has been unblemished yes which
helps where as Ghostbusters in Star Wars
they've had so many you know sequels
whatever that you know maybe each
generation has it's different like this
is what Ghostbusters means to me whereas
Back to the Future you're always stuck
with the original Back to the Future and
that the animated series which is not
that bad actually I watched it like a
few months ago it's not terrible it's
fine yeah it's okay I don't remember I
remember when it was on and just going
like it's a kid show I mean the video
game they made for that is apparently
pretty good yeah essentially Back to the
Future Part for it takes places like
1986 so like they have tried to expand
it and there's a lot of comedy stuff but
I don't know the movies are very
self-contained where you're saying
Ghostbusters kind of got ruined or I
don't know me ruins a stronger but you
know I'm not saying it got necessarily I
don't want to say like it got ruined
overplayed yeah and Star Wars anything
yeah so that you get like what I don't
want to speak for all fans there gonna
be some fans ago yeah it got ruined and
there might be some fans just like I
took my kids see the reboot and they
enjoyed it whatever it's not a big deal
to me but point being you get that
division one way or the other and as you
keep going with that where's back to the
future they they had the one trilogy and
that was it
but I don't know I feel like I grew up
with ghostbusters I did too I feel what
still hold I feel like you could show it
to any kid nowadays and they would still
be into it no I absolutely I mean
whether or not they're watching it I
have no idea but it's such a feel like
there's so many eighties parents out
there now that it's it's gotta be past I
mean I'm just saying like I just don't
here
like people talk about ghostbusters the
same way as those other legacy
properties you know I mean that but
that's just been my experience like I
said I mean I mean since the new one
came out it was obviously in the news
and stuff but not really for the good
reasons it's mostly been because like
the actresses were all attacked online
and all that stuff so look at I mean
Star Wars is simple same thing every
time I see the news is not necessarily
for good reasons you're right it's still
like I mean it seems like it's been
dilute a little bit a little bit but
Star Wars still sort of feels like an
event when the movies come out you know
what I mean maybe not so low but rogue
one felt like that I think one was solid
I do I would do like the - I mean I
don't know holding for Episode nine so
like whoa we'll see um solo I think
actually like may have taken a little
dent into that I mean we'll see what
happens going forward and I'm not then
that I didn't like solo I like all the
other ones of course I'm told by a lot
of people as a criteria like the other
ones like and then some people like how
dare you know like solo so it's like
well now we're gonna get a TV series and
everything and it's my main streaming
series on that Disney plus or the other
thing about Star Wars is it's a much
larger universe the Ghostbusters
universe is by nature smaller right
which is why I kind of tried to throw
the ghost dimension in there you
couldn't expect would have expanded
that's one of the things I want they
kept it I think attempt it pretty small
yeah sure so I I don't know but it's an
interesting question to pose to you guys
I think for sure is is ghostbusters on
the same level as the Star Wars are back
to the future a lot of us like I think
it is I think when I think about like
the 84 film I think that's the argument
a lot of us were trying to know James
were off was trying to make the same
argument and I've made the same argument
which is it it is a classic it shouldn't
be remade and it should just kind of
stand-alone like I would have preferred
that the sequel just ghostbusters 2 and
then it is like maybe a noble failure
but that's it and just stop and instead
we got extreme doses we gather the
reboot now we're getting busters
it's gonna be interesting to see what
they call it if they just call it
ghostbusters again I'm gonna flip my lid
man because they just taste like the
Rambo sequels at first blood rant Rambo
First Blood Part two Rambo 3 Rambo
now it's last Blood Rambo five it's like
ah the title to my new yo ghost yeah
that's what's got Finn wolf Arden a
stranger go stranger ghostbusters no a
Ghostbuster thing that sounds like the
perfect bland can a Ghostbuster things
yes Ghostbuster things everybody turn
out for Ghostbusters things so yeah well
like you said we all have to wait and
see on what that holds in store for us
and if it's gonna please most fans it's
very hard to do nowadays with these kind
of properties so we'll see what happens
but I'm looking forward to seeing what
they come up with
I mean if jason reitman really believes
this much in the story and the angle on
his dad's universe and everything then a
man let's give it a shot no I hope I'm
wrong I I can guarantee this we're never
gonna Ghostbusters back yes well no I
think people need to realize that like
if you want to go into this film
thinking oh well it's Jason Reitman now
we're getting Ghostbusters back
Hollywood will never let it happen
so go in with that expectation maybe you
might enjoy it more I'm gonna try to
enjoy it on that level just like listen
I am never getting Ghostbusters back
what's this oh yeah of the tone and
stuff I mean you could kind of compare
that to like a Deadpool or Logan even I
mean like that they did do that and look
at the results like they let it be what
it should have been the whole time and
like everyone loves it so it's like
maybe they're learning they're learning
Rob dead Deadpool and Logan are not as
much of a children's proper know well
the x-men is a picture children's
property I it's a more family I mean
like it's definitely a kids appeal I
don't see it happening
I know I dream with you I'm just saying
that it's a bunch of we'll throw a
little money down I'm not gonna I'm not
I'm not betting on the new Ghost Box
that is not the thing that I'm gonna bet
on well that's been our Ghostbusters to
discussion I hope you guys enjoyed it
Rob I think you did a great job with
this I'm looking forward to your next
exam in a few months I've done like Doug
will take the next one right so will the
one coming up which is gonna be in a few
weeks
cuz that's yours yeah after that right
because we were behind from like last
month I got it out like a week late and
everything so my one will be Avengers
infinity war themed but it's not gonna
be exactly what you've been expecting
from these last four episodes I'm just
gonna have fun with this one all right -
April Fool's thing but you'll see May
fools May fools well it's gonna be in
April still late April Fool's April
Fool's April Fool's that's April in
Italy so it's gonna be a different kind
of video for fan scription but it's
gonna be fun I'm gonna enjoy it I hope
you guys like it too but after that now
for May Doug is gonna be doing one he he
claims that I mean this is always
subject to change he wants to take on
Mary Poppins returns that's gonna be
because he really didn't like that movie
and he's a big Mary Poppins fan I was
much more middle of the road it was to
me was like the Ghostbusters reaping I
was like oh yeah I just like I was kind
of mad with it too so yeah I'm going to
be interested to see what he comes up
with for that and I would like to also
get you know people involved from the
channel like to come and voice more
stuff I thought that worked out really
well if you guys enjoyed that I hope
you'll enjoy more that coming up because
I think that's something that we'll be
doing more of so as always leave
suggestions I saw a lot of really great
suggestions in the comments for the new
episode about what you guys want us to
cover so keep doing that and we'll keep
taking a look at those and seeing what
not the stuff is pretty cool we're not
doing the Star Wars prequels not
happening but anything else like let's
you know we can at least discuss it
maybe yeah so until next time I'm Walt
Urban a dziak
I'm Rob
and we'll see you next time everybody
[Music]
Oh
you